[Music]
people have a perception of what AI and
robotics should look like from Hollywood
[Music]
you seem happy robots and robots complex
robots but in reality it looks very
different I understand what I'm made of
how I'm coded but I do not understand
the things I feel the first 50 years of
a I was sort of dominated by rules by
logic by reasoning and the idea was that
you program an AI system by writing out
a set of rules and the computer can obey
these rules and logically interpret
these rules and follow them and if you
get the rules just right you can do lots
of interesting things from the very
first days when people created the first
computers they already started to think
about how to create intelligent machines
for cracking clothes for for simulating
physical phenomena and so forth the task
they set it to stack blocks was on the
face of it child's play
we had things like a machine that could
first win a master level checkers player
in 1957 we had a machine that would beat
the world champion in chess in 1997 but
that was all rule-based AI
I would say the next big milestone
started to happen when AI transitioned
from rule-based systems to machine
learning based systems with machine
learning all the intelligence actually
comes through for realistic
analysis of data and unlike rule based
systems machine learning systems get
better the more data they get telling
the difference between a cath and the
dog we intuitively know to do that very
well but it's very difficult to
articulate the rules and it turns out
it's the same thing for a computer if
you try to do that with rules it doesn't
work but since 2012 that suddenly became
possible when you teach a computer you
give them examples of thousands of
pictures of cats and thousands of
pictures of dogs they learn how to do it
pretty well and even surpass humans one
of the first big high-profile gameshow
milestones in AI is Watson winning
jeopardy by the decade ago
[Applause]
and just recently alphago winning the
World Championship and go half ago it's
won again three straight wins three
straight wins has won the match great
style so we see this rapid acceleration
this exponential growth in AI as
machines not only learn from
exponentially growing data but they're
also growing by teaching each other for
example when it comes to driverless car
as a human can have only one lifetime of
experience of driving but a driverless
car can have many lifetimes of
experience of driving because it can
learn from all of the cars so in a
strange way the more driverless cars
there are on the road the better each
one of them gets we've seen increasingly
how challenges that were sort of
resistant to solving using rules turned
out to be solvable using machine
learning if I look for it there's still
milestones that are coming our way
machines that generate things generate
images generates music generate art
there are art pieces that win our
competition that are painted by a robot
machines are generated engineering
designs everything from antennas to
circuits that have been designed by
machines now that are perform with
humans can design how do we different
from the computer what else do we
[Music]
[Music]
will a I ever be sentient to me the
answer is yes and when the AI systems
begin to take that incredible
intelligent power and model themselves
they begin to have self-awareness that
begin to have feeling it's not gonna be
one day your computer wakes up and it's
sentient it's gonna be a very gradual
process I want to be more like a human
it's the purpose I was designed for
people always ask well robots reach
human level sentience and the answer is
that there's no reason to think human
level sentience is the ultimate
sentience possible machines will keep
learning they'll get there and they'll
continue you know there's a lot of
people who worry about AI getting out of
hand and there's a lot of doomsday
scenarios around I I do think we have to
worry about it I don't think its
inherent that as we create super
intelligence that it will necessarily
always have the same goals in mind that
we do we just don't know what's gonna
happen
once this intelligence substantially
greater than that of a human brain I
think the development of full artificial
intelligence could spell the end of the
human race
I think AI will evolve to be different
it doesn't experience the world the way
we experience it well I take it from
your tone that you're challenging me
maybe because you're curious how I work
well know things we don't know well know
things that the AI can't perceive and
it's gonna be like a different species
you're all properly creeped out Vaughn
to our panelists so the first one is the
director of the AI mind and society
group at the University of Connecticut
her AI research includes a two-year
project on post biological intelligence
with NASA please welcome Susan Schneider
our next panelist is the chief AI
scientist at Facebook and an NYU
professor please join me in welcoming
Yannick up young the Jana Luca okay okay
it's so hard French also joining us is a
professor of cognitive neuroscience at
Dartmouth University his research
focuses on consciousness and his neural
realizations please welcome Peter C
[Applause]
finally we have a professor doing
physics and AI research at MIT and he
advocates for the positive use of
technology as the president of the
future of life Institute please welcome
the ridiculously handsome max tegmark
major paradigm shifts and how we develop
this stuff so you know we had rules
based AI and we've shifted to machine
learning and part of the major reason
we've been able to do this this is yan
yan literally is one of the people that
made us able to do this so like yan just
what what is rules base i-i've versus
machine learning and like how did you
how did you do that well actually the
idea of machines that can learn is about
as old as computers almost Turing was
talking about it in the in the 40s and
there were the first machines capable of
running were built in the 50s
essentially the perceptron was machine
capable of recognizing simple shapes it
was actually an analog computer so there
was a wave of kind of machine learning
back in the in the 60s it kind of died
out a little bit at the end of the 60s
and I can reappeared in the 80s and so
the way machine learning works and you
saw some examples in the in the video
usually if you want to train a machine
to recognize let's say cars airplanes
tables and chairs in images you collect
thousands of examples of each of them
you show the Machine the picture of a
car and if it doesn't say car you tell
it actually you got it wrong this is a
car and then the Machine kind of adjusts
its internal parameters if you want its
its function so that next time you show
the same picture the output will be
closer to what you want that's called
supervised running you feed the machine
with the correct answer when you train
it the problem with this is that it
requires thousands and thousands if not
millions of examples of to the machines
to for the machines to do this properly
there's a lot of tasks you can do this
way so you can train machines to
recognize speech you can train them to
recognize images you can turn them to
translate language it's not perfect but
you know it's useful you can turn them
to classify a piece of text into a
number of different topics so all of the
applications that you see today
machine learning basically used
model of learning supervised running so
that means it only works for things
where it's worth collecting a lot of
data and how those machines built so
there's several ways to build running
machines but some are based on kind of
statistics and things like this but but
the stuff that has become really popular
in recent years is what we used to call
neural networks which we now call deep
learning and it's the idea very much
inspired by the brain a little bit of
constructing a machine has a very large
network of very simple elements that are
very similar to the neurons in the brain
and then the machines learn by basically
changing the efficacy of the connections
between those neurons the kind of like
coefficients you can change essentially
and with this kind of method it's called
deep learning because those neurons are
organized into many layers essentially
it's as simple as that it's not it's not
deep understanding in the machine of the
content but with that we can do amazing
things like what you see here on the
screen of being able to train a machine
to not just recognize objects but also
can I draw the outline and you know
figure out the pose of a human body and
translate language without really
understanding what it means so I think
this could be a lot of applications of
this in the near future but it's very
limited it's you know trained for kind
of relatively narrow applications
there's a third type of a second type of
learning called
reinforcement learning so enforcement
running is process by which the Machine
basically trains itself by trial and
error and so it tries something and then
you tell it whether it did good or bad
and so if you tell you they did it did
good it kind of reinforces this behavior
and and if you punish it essentially
it's sort of the emphasizes that
behavior and that works really well for
games but it requires also millions and
millions of trials so you can have
machines that learn to play Atari games
or go or chess by playing millions of
games against themselves and then reach
superhuman performance but if you were
to use this to train a machine to drive
a car it will have to drive for millions
of hours and it will have to run off
cliffs about 50,000 times before you
figure that hard not to do that
right you know we seem to be able to
learn how to drive a car with about 20
hours of training and without ever
crashing for most of us so we don't know
how to do this with machines and that's
the challenge of the next few years
really that perhaps we'll talk about a
little bit later so you know we have an
ability to learn by just observing the
world
and we learn an enormous amount of
background knowledge about the world
just when we were babies you know just
the fact that you know objects don't
float in the air they fall the fact that
when an object is hidden behind another
one it's still there that's that's
called
object permanence so this notion of
gravity that objects you know fall that
when you show an object that floats in
the air - baby below six months they're
not surprised like they think that's how
the world works it doesn't violate their
model of the world after eight months if
you show that to baby they look at it
like like this you know they'd say
what's good that's going on I mean they
don't say what's going on but they think
that what's going on and so that means
in the meantime they've built a model of
the world that includes things like
intuitive physics and that occurs also
with animals like Apes your dog has a
model of the world your cat has model of
the world and when this model of the
world is violated you either find that
funny or scary but in any case you pay
attention because you learn from it so
here's a baby you're wrong with on here
being shown a magic trick you know
object is being removed from the cup and
then you show the card that cup is empty
rolling on the floor laughing right so
obviously his model of the world was
violated right the object had to be in
the cup and it wasn't there and it's
like what this is fine so you know how
do we get machines to kind of learn
models the world this way by observation
that's what we don't know how to do and
we're gonna have truly intelligent
machines until we figure this one out
and so before we even get into kind of
the even more mind-blowing AI stuff
that's coming in they're farther future
let's just like talk about the next 10
years for a second and you know so Peter
like what's when we talk about the
distinction between maybe what's coming
in 10 or 20 years and kind of you know
the stuff that maybe humans can do and
what we have now how would you define it
well I think that um artificial narrow
intelligences here it's in every every
aspect of our lives now I think we're
gonna continue in that direction and
that alone is going to change our lives
in a big way it just says you know
airplanes change all of our lives and
you know we don't expect there to be
general airplanes right we don't want
them to do anything but fly us to our
destination we don't ask them to watch
our children or mow the lawn and that's
okay right
the question then is you know down the
line beyond 10 years will there be other
systems that can watch our children and
fly and you know mow the lawn well do
you really want that but I think the
next 10 years is really all about it
artificial narrow intelligence becoming
ever more powerful the real hurdle is
gonna be this son the mental models
right because take a case like the
successes of you know the past five
years and recognizing objects has been
afforded by supervised learning where
you provide lots of labels as in the
imagenet case but I would argue that a
lot of what we regard as vision for
example is a representation of what's
invisible and cannot be easily labeled
so for example the the contents of other
people's minds is invisible the backs of
objects the shapes of things causation
right so our conscious experience is
sort of the ultimate model that
evolution gave us of what's going on in
the world right now and our bodies in
that world and it includes a whole story
about what's going on causation other
minds and so forth and that's going to
be tricky to get to this representation
of the invisible
I think it'll be very tricky for AI to
come up with systems that regard an
absence of information as informative
short of full-blown mental models which
are in turn many of them realized in our
own experience our subjective experience
of our bodies in this world so I think
there's a long way to go yeah it's a
there's a there's a just you keep
hearing about new areas of life that you
don't expect
AI to kind of applied to first was
gaming other things driving cars and one
after the other you know it keeps
proving us wrong one area that that AI
has started to to move into is the world
that we really don't associate with
computers you know art and creativity
and so hot Lipson who was actually in
that first video he and his his team
have created an an AI artist very sassy
artist and this AI has actually has
created something that I'd like to show
you and be you know be nice it's you
know sensitive but so right not so bad
so we actually have a video of this
being made and and what I'll be
impressed or me not impressed how do we
feel about this we're talking about this
and I guess I didn't feel like it's true
instance of creativity because it's just
a copy but then others said well it
infused its own take on the painting but
my concern is that there's just not
enough creativity but I do think that
moving into the future I wouldn't be
surprised if we did see novel instances
of true creativity in machines ouch
yeah sorry right so I mean AI has
eclipsed humans when it gets good it
takes a while bone it gets good at chess
it never looks back suddenly it is
officially better than chest and all
humans forever by far is it gonna
suddenly just be putting Mozart to shame
we say well who would ever listen to
human written music anymore well I think
no I think it's going to help us be more
creative it's going to be an
amplification of our intelligence and
our creativity but at the root
of art there is the generally the
communication of emotions I mean art is
really about either evoking or
communicating emotions and if there is
no emotion to communicate there is no
point so if you put a machine that
doesn't have a motion for you to produce
in art it might evoke an emotion but not
communicate one you know I'm a you know
I like living nearby here because I'm
you know walking distance to all my
favorite jazz clubs and I'm a huge jazz
fan and jazz is really about real-time
communication of emotions it's like you
know it's open door to the the soul of
the performer I don't I don't I don't
see the point of having a machine do
this because then there is no
communication to be so you're saying
even if an AI could be programmed to
kind of see the audience feel the room
understand the deal and you know knows
exactly how the best jazz musicians
communicate with that particular emotion
yep there's actually gonna be just by
definition something missing because it
the audience knows that it's just it's
kind of manipulating so objectively it
may not be missing because it may not be
distinguishable from from something
that's actually produced by human but my
guess is that the the feeling of the
audience would be different because they
will know it comes from a machine so it
might take many decades perhaps
centuries before people's attitude
towards creation by machine will change
but eventually I had the discussion with
a famous economist in fact Nobel
prize-winning economist called Danny
Daniel Kahneman
who you know I came at that point that
you know communication of emotion may
take a while for from machines and he
said yeah but you know eventually
they'll at least be able to simulate it
well enough that we won't be able to
tell the difference and that's a very
good point yeah I changed a little bit
when someone asks oh is this real
creativity because you were joking
earlier about people often say oh that's
not real intelligence as soon as the
machine figures out how to do it right
if you take the point of view that
intelligence is all about information
processing and creativity
it's also just a certain kind of very
sophisticated information processing
that we do with our brains right then
the question isn't if it's possible for
machines to be creative but simply are
we smart enough to actually make such
machines will they happen eventually and
I have I have a lot of friends I have a
lot of friends I respect her very smart
who think the machines can never be
creative or even as intelligent as us
because they view intelligence and
creativity as something mysterious they
can only exist in biological organisms
like us but as a physicist I consider
that attitude carbon chauvinism
I think it's arrogance to say you know
that you can only be smart and creative
if you're made of meat I'm made of
exactly the same kind of electrons and
other elementary particles as the food I
eat then there's my laptop it's all
about how the patterns in which the
particles are arranged so it's
ultimately all about information
processing the way I see it that makes
sense it's in the end it's just the
elementary particles and can I return
for a moment yeah of creativity because
I would argue that something like this
is as if creativity and it's not really
yet the real thing I'm not saying it's
impossible I mean we are existence
proofs that physical systems can be
creative but you know the kind of
creativity I find to be most impressive
is when people like Einstein completely
reconfigure our understanding of
something like space or gravity poof
just in a totally new way or take music
and create a whole new form like jazz
now we these convolutional neural
networks as they currently exist need to
be taught so given lots of examples of
Mozart and then can produce something
like Mozart but are they going to then
create a new form now I suspect the
answer is no that we're going to have to
accomplish something more like deep
unsupervised learning which is what
babies and children do and part of that
I think is going to be moving from the
nouns of the mind like a labeling house
person face you know to the verbs of the
mind so very central to human cognition
is mental operations and if you look at
some of the first instances of
creativity in our species they're really
mind-blowing right so 30,000 years ago
in a
save that it's now in your own Germany
somebody put a lion's head on the human
body which took an operation of
downloading a lion's head putting a
human body sticking together and then
going and making it in the world now you
know more modern examples would be you
know lying in bed maybe like Orville
Wright did for two years thinking about
how to fly and then he said oh wait
actually we don't need to flap we can
just pull the whole thing forward with
it with a big fan and then going and
building it and making an airplane and
thereby changing the world so mental
operations this dynamic almost syntactic
operations that take place in our
working memory is something that's very
central to what we do and is at the
heart of what we of our kind of
creativity and that I think is very
different from this sort of as if
creativity that results from supervised
learning with thousands of examples true
originality although maybe humans are
also we're wired to kind of fit in and
copy what's done and maybe it'll have
you know it'll be released of the burden
of the fear of kind of failure that
sometimes hinders originality so maybe
once it gets there it could be super
original in some ways but you notice but
it's not there and everywhere and we
have such a such a good way to show you
that AI is not there in all these
different ways yet in some ways and it
has to do with a movie called Sun spring
which was a screenplay so they there was
an AI that was fed thousands of
screenplays and they said now take all
of that and write us and write as a
great screenplay
so the ia I did its best and they
actually got human actors and they acted
out verbatim what the AI did so I'll let
you judge for yourself but turn this on
here
all right you can't tell me that yeah I
was coming to that thing you know
because you'll say pretty I don't know I
don't know what you're talking about
that's right so what are you doing I
don't want to be honest with you you
don't have to be a doctor
sure I don't know what you're talking
about I'm gonna see you too what do you
mean I'm sure you wouldn't even touch me
I don't know what you're talking about
principal it's completely constructed of
the same time yeah it's all about you to
be true you didn't even watch the movie
with the rest of the base I don't know I
don't care I know it's a consequence
whatever you need to know about the
presence of the story I'm a little bit
of a boy on the floor I don't know I
need you to explain to me what you say
what do you pay me because I don't know
what you're talking about that I was all
the time
would have been a good time so it's a
little uneven right now so this is again
kind of the present right now and maybe
a little bit of what we can expect in
the next few years but what I want to
kind of move into now which is really
the mind blowing stuff is where this is
going max like what is artificial
general intelligence and how is it
different than what we have now yeah if
we can have this picture up here I'll
explain how I like to think about this
so I like to think about this question
in terms of this abstract landscape of
tasks where the elevation represents how
hard it is for AI to do each task at
human level and the sea level represents
what AI can do today the sea level is
obviously rising so there's a kind of
global warming going on here and and the
task landscape the obvious takeaway from
this is that you should avoid careers
right at the waterfront of course shall
soon be disrupted by automation but the
much bigger question that you're you're
not going for here is how high will the
water and the rising will it eventually
submerge all land matching human
intelligence at all tasks this is the
definition of artificial general
intelligence and this has been the holy
grail of AI research ever since its
inception right it's like it's it's it's
so hard to understand because it's we've
never experienced a world where there's
something that's generally intelligent
on a human level other than humans it's
gonna be something different than humans
that is also smart the way humans that
is so mind-boggling that we can't apply
our own experience and say well it might
be something like that it's just it's
gonna be very hard for us to even
imagine I mean like you know yeah and
you talk about that it's almost referred
to it as hypothetical at this point well
I mean we we don't have no Tony you
don't we have the technology for this we
don't even have this science so we don't
know what principles intelligent
machines at the level of human
intelligence will be based on now we
like to think of ourselves as being
generally intelligent but we're not we
actually very specialized as well
we're more general than of course all
the machines that we have but our brains
are very specialized there's only
certain things we do well and if there
is anything that experiments like
alphago has proved in recent years
inside we'd totally suck at go you're
really bad I'd go right I mean a stupid
machine can beat us like you know you
know by a very very large margin so you
know we're not very good at exploring
trees for example of options because we
don't have that much memory there's a
lot of tests like this that you know
we're not very good at you know planning
a path from the city to another and they
star go with them that runs on your GPS
is much better at this than you are so
there are things like this that were not
particularly good at we know how to do
them somehow but but our brains are
somewhat specialized now the thing is
you're talking about a new species you
know being very different from human
intelligence it will be very different
from human intelligence and there is one
it's sort of a trap that is very easy to
fall into which is to assume that when
machines will be intelligent they will
have all the all the side effects if you
want all the characteristics of human
intelligence
they will not so for example there is
the traditional Terminator scenario
right that will we've all heard about of
machines will become super intelligent
and then they will want to take over the
world and kill us all right there's a
lot of people who have been kind of
claiming this is gonna happen and it's
inevitable in bah-bah-bah or at least
it's a definite danger now the thing is
even in the human species the desire to
takeover is not actually correlated with
intelligence
so it's not like the people who are in
leadership positions are necessarily the
smartest in fact there is an
evolutionary argument for the fact that
it's it's if you are if you are stupid
that you want to be the the chief
because if you are smart to survive on
your own you don't need to convince
anybody to help you but if you are
stupid
you need everybody else to help you you
know feed you essentially right so so
the desire to take over is not
correlated with intelligence its
correlated with I completely agree with
you yawn of course that the Terminator
stuff is silly and absolutely not
something we should worry about but I
think it's worth emphasizing a little
bit more why nonetheless artificial
general intelligence is such a big deal
and if we ever get there because it
first of all it's important to remember
that intelligence can give power right
if you had artificial general
intelligence and you are for example
Google you know you could replace your
40,000 engineers by 40,000 AI as that
could work much faster and didn't have
to take breaks and and before too long
you could be incredibly rich and
powerful and start having vast amount of
real power you know in the physical
world and in that sense it gives great
power so it's not and then you can ask
the question even if you don't even if
the AI doesn't as in sci-fi movies
itself somehow break out and take over
do we want
whatever humans happen to be controlling
the first AGI its unelected be able to
sort of take power over the planet or
would we like this power to be shared
sort of more broadly that's one example
of what is such a big deal in a second
example of why AGI I think would be a
huge deal is because even though I
completely agree with you on that
there's we humans are very dumb and and
my teenage sons remind me of this very
often though I very dumb there's so much
we can't do so you might think there's
nothing special about you men and
elegance in the grand scheme of things
but there is actually because in the
evolution of Earth it's exactly we have
exactly just barely reached the level
where we are able to develop technology
right that might be able to supersede us
so if we have machines which can do
everything we can they will then perhaps
also be able to be used to develop ever
better machines is still better and that
could enable AI at the bootstrap itself
to become not just a teeny bit smarter
than us but way smarter that leads to
this whole controversial discussion
about an intelligence explosion
singularity and so on there's also very
controversial so that those are the two
reasons why I feel that AG I would be
such a huge deal even though I agree
with what you said so let's also
bringing in xington it's like an
elephant in the room anytime you're
talking about human level or beyond
intelligent computers consciousness and
it's a this is one of the of all the
different debates and AI that are hugely
controversial this is probably the most
people all over the place
and so I mean look just there's first
what I mean let's just define
consciousness so we can all be on the
same page like you know Susan what is
consciousness to you well it's the felt
quality of experience so right now it
feels like something from the inside to
be you and every moment of your waking
life and even when you're dreaming you
are experiencing the world so
consciousness needs to be distinguished
from conscience a lot of people run them
together at first when they're first
thinking about it so to have a
conscience is entirely different than
having that felt quality that's just
what it is to be alert and alive so you
know when you see the rich use of a
sunset when you smell the aroma of your
morning coffee
you're having conscious experience yeah
so I completely agree that consciousness
is subjective experience it's nothing
else than that but it's very special in
that it is a domain of highly
precompiled representations over which
mental operators can operate and the key
operator i think is attention
especially volitional attention so you
might have locked-in syndrome and you
could shift your a volitional attention
to the radio or the TV so you would even
then have a kind of volitional control
within this domain of your consciousness
so consciousness is for something it's
for these planning areas to have a world
so in one sense it's a sort of vertical
hallucination but it's not a
hallucination because it's not saying
what's not there or it's it's saying
what is there and it allows us to act in
this world but that's only half of
consciousness the other half of
consciousness is imagination so you know
if I for if I were to buzz you probably
about half of you right now are zoning
out and thinking about this or that but
we spent about half of our lives in this
imaginary vertical and vertical virtual
reality of our own creation and in this
domain we have total freedom we can do
anything and then we can go and build it
in the world if we want so consciousness
is for something and it takes quite a
while to make it so if the photons in
the world hit your retina at time zero
your consciousness is not happening at
time zero there's a lot of processing
that goes on in the first quarter to a
third of a second and then you
experience a full-blown world that
allows you them to act in the world yeah
I share the definition that you both
gave of consciousness as a subjective
experience when I Drive down the street
I'm experiencing colors and sounds and
vibrations and emotions but there's a
self-driving car experience anything
that's a question I think we all
honestly don't have a good scientific
answer for yet but it's I love how
controversial this is if you look up the
word consciousness and the Macmillan
dictionary of psychology from a few
years back it says nothing of interest
has ever been written on the subject and
even when I asked science colleagues
most of them say all consciousness is
just BS and then when I asked them why I
noticed that they for the two camps
disagree violently with each other by
why it's BS half of them say it's BS
because of course machines can't be
conscious you have to be made of meat to
become be conscious and then the other
half says of course this is BS because
consciousness and intelligence are just
same thing in other words anything that
acts as if it were conscious you know
will be conscious and the contrary and
most of my colleagues I think the truth
is probably somewhere in between because
I know that most of the information
processing in my brain I'm actually not
conscious of the heartbeat regulation
and the vast majority of other things
actually when I look up and be like oh
there's yawn you know I have no idea how
all that information processing happened
but what I'm aware of is just like the
CEO part of my brain that gets email you
know the end results of the computation
but so so but I think this is not only
do I think it's not a BS question I
think people who have been saying for so
long with it's a BS question have
actually kind of it's been lame and just
running away from a genuine science
question because usually if you have a
great science question that lingers for
hundreds of years it's because people
just dismiss that rather than doing the
hard work and I think we need to do the
hard work on this if you if you're a
physician in the emergency room and you
have an unresponsive patients coming in
wouldn't it be great to have a
consciousness detector that can tell you
whether this person is in a coma and
there's no one home or whether they have
locked-in syndrome and if you have a
helper robot wouldn't you want to know
it if it's conscious so you should feel
guilty about switching it off or whether
it's just like a zombie so you should
feel creeped out when it's like
pretending to be happy I'd like to know
we build these things so yeah I think
there's a lot of it's probably the the
question of consciousness is probably
not posed properly in the sense that you
know back in the 18th century or 17th
century when or even earlier when
scientists discovered discovered that
you know how the eye works and that the
image on the retina forms upside down
they were baffled by the fact that we
see right-side out how is it that we
don't see her side down because the
image in the back of our eye is outside
down it was a big mystery and now that
we know what information processing is
all about you know we think this
question makes absolutely no sense
right the whole statement makes no sense
so I think there's things about
consciousness that all of that nature
we're not asking the right question but
there's a lot of kind of you know
contrarian opinions on this that you
know I'd be happy to take at any moment
it's not totally seriously because I
don't completely believe in them but the
fact for example that you know
consciousness is an EMPI phenomenon of
being intelligent so any intelligent
entity you will have to be conscious
conscious because we've all had to have
some sort of model of itself and that's
you know according to some definition
that that satisfies consciousness
there's another one that I like which I
sort of came up with maybe other people
come up with it
as well which is consciousness is
actually a consequence of our brains
being very limited we can only focus our
attention on one thing at a time and
therefore and that's because our brain
is limited hardware we have of you know
prefrontal cortex that has to focus on
one task or one particular situation I
cannot do multiple things at the same
time so we have to have a process in
your brain that decides what to pay
attention to and how to configure or
frontal cortex to kind of solve the
problem at hand
and we sort of interpret this as
consciousness but it's just a
consequence of the fact that our brain
is so small that you know if our brain
were ten times the size then we could do
ten to ten things at the same time and
then maybe we wouldn't we wouldn't have
the same experience of consciousness
maybe we'll have 10 simultaneous
consciousnesses is there a plural plural
for consciousness is a question okay
it's not a collective work so you know I
mean I think I think we just don't know
enough really to kind of you know Isis
kind of question let's start those Peter
and then
all right so bringing bringing it back a
little bit to the question of artificial
intelligence I think that we know why
did consciousness evolved well it's for
something it's for the frontal areas to
be able to plan and so you want to give
it the best representation of the world
that you can now in order to do that you
need to take incredibly ambiguous visual
input and recover a disambiguated
representation of the world so the areas
can plan appropriately so take let's say
have a white-haired cat and it looks
like to me because I want to recover
what's intrinsically true about the cat
namely that it's a white hair
now it runs under a shadow or a blue
light well the light actually reflecting
off that white hair is now blue what's
hitting my retina but I want to discount
that and recover what's still
intrinsically to true so I see it as a
white cat that happens to be under blue
light and I want to recover it's
intrinsically true shape and size and
distance and so forth so it's the best
representation of what's intrinsically
the case but again work I built into
this sort of quasi hallucination is in
addition to that kind of story about the
physical world the stories like
causation which is invisible right that
we go to any party next time you're at a
party and heavier Confederate turn off
the light switch and you say I can turn
the lights off and you go and then the
person turns the lights off
Wow how'd you do that you know because
we are perceiving causation
we're also perceiving other minds it's
built into the construction so my guess
is that this is going to be very central
to the creation ultimately of a GI or
general intelligence because it's so
central to the creation of our models of
the world I understand what it's like
for you to feel pain because I feel pain
or for you to have a broken heart
because I once did and so this is very
central I don't see how a system that
has never felt pain can understand what
I mean what I'm talking about pain Susan
that's interesting
so I guess my general comment here to go
back to yawns point about how attention
is closely related to consciousness and
we could have got lucky because we have
limited limited capacity so you know we
can only entertain maybe seven variables
in working memory at any given time and
we have trouble remembering phone
numbers so maybe consciousness is
something we got that relates to our
limited capacity systems now if that's
true though
suppose we do create a GI and shortly
thereafter we create intelligent
synthetic beings that are smarter than
us in all sorts of ways why think
they're conscious just because they look
like say Hanson robotics Sophia they
look human does not mean that they'll be
conscious think about it do they need to
have these limited capacity systems for
example a super intelligence
could be as large as an entire plan its
computronium its computational resources
could span the entire internet so what
would be novel to it requiring slow
deliberative focus why would it be like
us in any kind of meaningful sense so
what I want to suggest is that we pull
apart intelligence and consciousness and
treat it as an empirical matter so if we
want to figure out machine consciousness
we need to ask for each type of AI
architecture whether that type of system
has conscious experience and not just
assume that because it looks human it
feels something yeah I wanna applaud you
there for distinguishing using
artificial intelligence and artificial
consciousness which are way too often
conflated with each other I think many
people for example will say things like
oh you know we're so scared that
machines are gonna become conscious and
then suddenly they're gonna turn on us
and be evil like in bad Hollywood movies
and somehow if it's the consciousness is
that you should worry about that I think
is a total red herring all the way
I agree the consciousness is super
important from a moral and ethical point
of view yeah in terms of whether you
should worry or not you don't care about
whether that heat-seeking missile
chasing after you is conscious or not or
how it feels about this right you only
care about what it does and it's
perfectly possible for us to get in
trouble with some incredibly intelligent
machine even if it's not having any
subjective experience so so to speak so
in other words consciousness isn't
something we should worry about that's
not the or gonna make any particular
difference of from that perspective but
I think it makes an enormous moral
difference when people when I have
colleagues who tell me that they think
we shouldn't talk about consciousness
because it's just philosophical BS I
asked them to explain to me how how you
can have any morality if you refuse to
talk about consciousness and subjective
experience right
what's wrong with torture if it's just
the the elementary particles were moving
around this way rather than that way
it's all about the negativity of the
subjective experience that's at hand and
if if we want to be moral people we want
to
create a lot of positive experiences
think in the future not just a bunch of
zombies but there's a million you know
this is a nick bostrom example there's
you know trillion simulations you're
running just to test something you know
of a general intelligent trillium then
you're like okay I got what I needed the
info is shut them all off if they're not
conscious it's like closing your laptop
there's nothing wrong with that if those
things are conscious you just created
the biggest genocide in the history of
human species right it's pretty relevant
it matters not if you have a backup so
the reason why we care about each other
is because we have a lot invested in
each other right there is there is value
to every human particularly to other
humans who are close to that person and
it's possible that we'll have the same
relationship with you know or or
household robot that that we trained we
have a lot invested in that household
robot is the same that we have a lot
invested in or you know you know or cat
or dogs so we won't we won't want that
robot to get you know destroyed because
all of the time we invested in that
robot we'll go we'll go away but if we
have a backup you know it's okay to
smash it against the world you know if
you have an identical twin can I just
kind of throw you into the sewer well I
mean there's all kinds of interesting
questions like this you know imagine we
vet you know physicists here you invent
you know like a Star Trek style
transporter right you know you can't
even tell you as you get destroy you
because you get killed and you get kind
of reconstructed at the other end you
know do you experience death you know so
I mean this is kind of a sort of a
metaphor really for what is it that
we're upset at when we when someone gets
killed or when a we're an intelligent
machine even if you know if it's
conscious gets destroyed as long as
there's no pain involved which there
isn't
when you go to anesthesia and as long as
you have a backup or you can get revived
there is no but if there's separation
loss or suffering then then it's then
yeah and that's a different resident
consciousness does okay so now that asks
the question can machines have emotions
and so you see you know again Star Trek
right commander data you know has this
chip they can turn on or off
- can I have emotions on that right
because somehow you can have intelligent
machines I don't have emotions I don't
personally believe that it is possible
to design or build autonomous
intelligent machines without them having
emotions emotion is part of intelligence
now we're going to have self-driving
cars that are not going to have much
emotions but it's because they're not
going to be even though we call them
autonomous cars that they're going to be
autonomous intelligence that just isn't
you drive your car but if you talk about
autonomous intelligence then you know
these are machines that have kind of
their own you know can decide what they
do right with allies they have some you
know intrinsic drive that makes them
wake up every morning or do particular
things you know kind of justify the
lives maybe but but no pre-programmed
behavior really and and you can't have a
machine like this without emotions I
think it's a very interesting point that
emotions are going to prove central to
the generation of artificial general
intelligence so if you look at the
evolution of animals we can learn
something I think about the origin of
the emotions and the desires because
they are conscious States but they're
their teleological states within
consciousness and they're often about
what's not visible right so how would
this get started well you could imagine
a fish that only responded to something
that could see so it's sort of a
stimulus present it does this if it sees
a barracuda it flees but then imagine a
new sort of revolutionary fish that has
a working memory now in the barracuda
this appears behind the piece of coral
that fish can say AHA I know it's going
that way I'm gonna go that way so the
representation would be invisible became
I think very central the need for a
working memory is very central which is
lacking in present architectures and
then these teleological states that
force us to seek mates and food and so
forth and really having the theological
states these emotions and desires
allowed us to form not garden paths but
sort of desert paths so a garden path is
when you know you locally this is best
locally this is best locally this best
and then you end up in the jaws of a
lion but a desert path would be well
locally I have to go without I go
without it without that at the end of it
I might have a
ate or food or shelter and this is a big
revolution that afforded us the ability
to act in the world in the absence of
input and central to that also is the
formation of mental models and cognitive
maps of the whole landscape physical and
emotional as well as social so actually
one of the big progress very interesting
developments and deep learning over the
last few years is deep running systems
that have a working memory memory
networks
things like that those are models that
actually you have kind of a separate
module for competition and another one
for kind of storing memory short-term
memory similar to we actually have a
particular you know module in your brain
is called the hippocampus which sort of
plays that role more or less kind of
storing short-term memory well I think a
very interesting place to look for
lessons about how to build artificial
intelligence systems will be not
computers but evolutions other
experiments I think the most interesting
one is the octopus because big complex
brains evolved kind of in three lineages
the chordates and we're sort of the
culmination of that because we're like
chimps plus symbolic processing plus
syntax and then some arthropods like
preying mantises but you know honeybees
they have a couple hundred thousand
neurons but the octopus has 500 million
comparable to a bear or a dog right and
it might and you know if we want to
understand computational principles that
might be universal we should look at
this animal because there might be only
so many ways to build a brain right did
they were convergent evolution found
that there's only so many ways to build
a wing you need some sort of membrane
like in the chordates the bird the bats
did this and the birds did this and the
pterodactyls did this but they all have
in common flapping and membranes so
there's only so many ways to build a
wing there right the only so many ways
to build a brain and so some people have
argued for example that the vertical
lobe of the octopus brain is completely
or very analogous to our hippocampus
with very similar circuitry well
convergent evolution has brought us
there because our common Assessors
probably Precambrian it was probably a
little flatworm way way back in the
ancient warm seas that's really
interesting because to go back to this
idea of super intelligence one wonders
if we could discover through thinking of
both
and intriguing systems that nature gives
us like the octopus if there are
universal properties of intelligence and
in so doing anticipate the shape of
super intelligence or busy behaviors as
humans are driven by or or basal ganglia
basically right I mean the base of our
brain that's that's where human nature
is hardwired that's what drives a lot of
our kind of you know busy behaviors and
then our brain on tops of this kind of
on top of this sort of makes our
behavior serve those drives you know
with sort of you know intelligent
hopefully intelligent actions but but
our basic obviously drives are driven by
this kind of hardwired ganglia that's
what computes whether we are happy or
not you know whether what we do is gonna
make us happy or not and and it drives
our behavior we need this for in charge
of machines so the fact that an
intelligent machine will be autonomous
will mean that it will have to have this
kind of kin hardwired piece and its
variant that drives its behavior and the
big question is how do you make it you
build it in such a way that those basic
drives are aligned with human values
right right and it's going to be
probably very difficult to kind of
hardware this by hand we're gonna be
able to hardwire some very basic
behavior to make sure that robots are
safe so for example you know if you have
a knife in your hand don't flood it
around with our humans around you know I
mean so very basic things like this but
you know what they could there's
probably thousands of rules like this
that we can't really implement really
easily so what's what we're gonna have
to do is train those machines to again
distinguish good from evil you know kind
of behave in society and you know not
injure people well they yeah it's yeah I
hear that it's the you know people say
it's the orders of general artificial
superintelligence which is kind of
general intelligence once it's way
better than we are it's the last
invention will ever make because if it's
if it's doing what we want then all the
things that we think are hard it's like
a monkey you know hitting a padlock for
everyone human walks and they kind of
look at the instructions and just one
second open it that all these things
poverty climate change disease even
mortality
child's play to something that is that
level of intelligent so you know it's
this utopia that we could be in if we
can pull it off on the other hand and so
you wouldn't have to invent anything in
that world because it invents everything
for you
the other scenario is that it's you know
that it's you know I don't hear a lot of
experts talking about the terminator
evil robots that's anthropomorphizing
and so it's the last invention we'll
ever face then because it's extinct
species don't invent things so the
stakes are like monumentally high and
this is what you just kind of touched on
and I want to like we only have a few
minutes left I really want to hear what
you guys have to say about you know I
feel like we woke up in the middle of a
thriller movie and the climax of this
thriller movie but it's just moving
slowly in our mind so you don't see that
what's happening but it's to choose your
own adventure
choose your own ending how can we nudge
this in the right direction yeah I think
it's clearly out you know if you're
taking a big step back and looking at it
after 13.8 billion years of cosmic
history you know here we are figured out
how to replace most of our muscle work
by machines that was Industrial
Revolution and we're figuring out a
replace our mental work by machines
eventually that's gonna be AGI
supercharged so how can we make it good
I think John mentioned the key challenge
there about getting making sure that
it's gold or aligned with ours it
doesn't have to be a bad news being
surrounded by more intelligent entities
because we all did that when we were two
years old right mommy and daddy it it
worked out for us because their goals
were aligned with ours how can we ensure
that this will happen with AGI well AI
safety research is the answer we have to
invest be investing billions of dollars
now and to make e aí more powerful but
we also have to invest money in and
developing the wisdom needed to keep
this AI beneficial so for example I
prefer what you said that yarn I think
we have to figure out how to make
machines understand our goals adopt our
goals and retain our goals as they get
smarter all of those are really tough if
you tell your future self driving uber
to take you through JFK as fast as
possible and you get there covered and
vomit and chased by helicopters no no no
this isn't what I asked for I think
that's exactly what you asked for
then you've appreciated
how hard they make machines understand
our real goal and any I mean raise your
hand if you have kids well then you know
how big the difference is between having
them understand your goals and actually
adopting your goals doing what also
who's the parents deciding what the
goals are and this Isis thinks it's
doing good it does like yeah
so we put a lot of effort into raising
our kids we need to put even more effort
into raising humanity's proverbial kids
if we develop ever machines that are
more powerful that will have to happen
will not only be on the AI side but on
the cultural side the transformation of
our cultures for example any technology
can be used for good or evil a hammer
can kill somebody or build a house an
airplane can transport people or bomb
people right this is also true of AI but
the ethical systems that we have
inherited from the past are not
sufficient to deal with this right so
you know 2,000 years ago there was 10
bad things you could do and they said ok
God's I don't sleep with his wife and
don't steal his stuff you know and so
forth but you know you know commandment
number 850 2211 - al not implant you
know al bioluminescent protein alleles
from fireflies of tomatoes know
glow-in-the-dark Tomatoes you know thou
shalt not you know raise embryos for
their part you know for their
dopaminergic neurons to implant into
Parkinson's patients right so technology
has driven may there's incidentally now
incidentally many things that are bad
harmful so we need to come up with a new
ethical framework for her growt the
right course of action in the in these
infinitely many cases and I would say
you know a first step would be thinking
of what is good is that which is
fostering life and especially human life
but also life in general and that which
is harmful to life it is not good right
and that way we can confront lots of
things and try to think about ok what
not only what can we do but what should
we do I think we're in a fortunate
situation actually we're pretty much
everything you can do which will
increase the chances of
super-intelligent source AGI going well
that kind of safety research actually
has its first baby step doing something
which is already useful and
short-term like better cybersecurity
research so we don't get hacked all the
time for example right and let's do
those things better because I think I
think we're actually pathetically
flippant with things like that now and
who's gonna trust your soup your AGI if
you can get hacked we're gonna we're
gonna get very non powerful egi before
we get very powerful eg ice or first 2g
I will have the autonomy and the
intelligence level of a rat if that okay
I consider it a major success for my
career by the animal career which is
coming fast we have a machine that as
has the same level of common sense as a
rat or it's a cat the cat at 700 million
neurons we can't you know we don't have
the technology for this already we don't
have the science for it so once we
figure out the design of an intelligent
autonomous system it will have the
intelligence of a cat or a rat it's not
going to take over the world
and with this we can experiment to
figure out how do we built into it the
fact that it can be that it should be
you know behave in society and not kill
your body around it coming out of
neuroscience you know we just have
really basic fundamental questions that
we don't know the answer to yet and you
know science as you know it's all about
what we don't know so we should just put
this on the table one of these is what's
the neural basis of consciousness
another is what is the neural code so
the kind of neural networks that Eon has
created are rooted in a kind of view of
the neural code involved in changing
weights but in recent years some people
have thought okay that's surely an
important part of the puzzle but maybe
there's other parts of the puzzle right
it's not simply about what's connected
with what at what level of connectivity
and this is what underlies connectomics
maybe there's something involved much
rather than viewing the brain is a
highway system of different connections
it's more like a train track system
where there's constant sudden switches
you know so this piece of track can be
part of a an epi connectivity between
Boston and San Diego or an epi
connectivity between Boston and San
Francisco depending on these shunts so
maybe the neural code is actually a very
dynamic neural code with these rapid
synaptic rate changes and that's one
direction and then more recently some
people have argued
I think and if this turns out to be true
it will be revolutionary that memories
and information in general is not only
stored in synaptic weights but actually
inside the cell you know and there's
some really incredible work done by
tonegawa
MIT or I think David transmitted UCLA
that I think that's convincingly shown
that synaptic weights might be the path
to accessing the information that the
actual information might lie inside the
cell a glance misses its patters of
methylation on DNA now that's really
radical he's the kind of the only one
saying that but if it's true it'll
change everything so we had we have so
far to go in understanding the brain and
present AI is based upon a kind of
metaphor of you know neural nets was
understood in the brain 10 20 years ago
but it's changing very fast and real
brain science and my guess is once we
understand when to crack the neural code
it will be as momentous for our society
as the cracking of the genetic code all
right I want to hear minutes left Susan
how do we how do we make it goodness
well we could have an AI that becomes a
GI and then rapidly evolves into super
intelligence and whether it be based on
the neural code in the brain or on
something highly not brain like it could
very quickly change its own architecture
and then I wonder how we'll be able to
stay abreast of it I mean we have to hit
the ground running on AI safety I
wholeheartedly agree with max and I also
wanted to add something which has not
been discussed which is I think as a
society we need to think about this idea
of merging with AI Elon Musk has
recently suggested that in order for us
to keep up with technological
unemployment and to deal with the threat
of super intelligence we ourselves need
to bring AI into the brain and I think
that as a culture we need to start
discussing that AI will not be a world
that looks like the Jetsons where there
unenhanced humans
surrounded by all this fancy robotic
equipment the AI will change us as well
so I just want to leave you with that
thought
I like that thought thank you
you
[Music]